أنا محاميه الأول و
المدافع الأول أعرفه الآن
ما دمت أعرف بيئته التي أعرفها
له حصريا على أنه مطلق
أنا أعلم
كما قلت ، بيئته لم تتغير أبدًا
لا تدع أي شيء يقع في الديون
هل كرة القدم نقية أمتلك أكمل ما لدي
كان لديه ثقة من قبل وفعل
بعد الخطأ الذي اقترفه
لكل فرد الحق لكل فرد
أيضا لارتكاب خطئي مرات عديدة
لسحب الخيوط التي كانت أكثر من اللازم
وهي ضد مدونة قواعد السلوك في
الفريق وبالتأكيد
مدونة قواعد سلوك بايرن ميونخ
من الواضح أن هذا هو
رأى أن له عذر
حدثت ذات مصداقية مطلقة
لا يوجد سبب على الاطلاق
على الإطلاق
شك وبالتالي
لديه لي هناك كمحامي دفاع و
المحامي إلى جانبه وكان أنا
من المهم أيضًا أن يبقى في
يبقى التدريب معها وكان هناك
كما أنه مهم للغاية للاعبين
يبقى في التدريب على الفور
إذا قام باستيراد هذا الآن
يجب أن المخلفات إلى الغرامة